we good
finally go here
okay just one you'll hear a voice and
then you're good to go
okay all right well welcome everybody
and uh those of you who are
uh listening uh online
there's some background noise coming
somewhere
okay i have a preliminary statement that
i i need to make based upon um
the governor's order here as chairman of
the
uh education committee uh i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the
governor as a result of covert 19
pandemic
and in accordance to the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020 day so for this public body is
authorized to meet electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however
in accordance with the emergency order i
am confirming that we
are a uh providing public access to the
meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means
uh we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting all members of the
committee and selected staff have
the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaries
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary
participate in this meeting by clicking
on the following website
address that address is
https colon backslash
backslash zoom dot u s
backslash j backslash
nine seven two three
six two six one eight
zero eight or dialing one of the
following phone numbers
one three one two six two
six six seven nine nine
or one nine two nine
two zero five six zero
nine nine b
providing the public access providing
public notice
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
we previously noticed that the public of
necessary information
for accessing the meeting including how
to access a meeting using zoom or
telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
c providing a mechanism for
public to alert the public body during
the meeting if there is a problem with
access if anybody has a problem
please call 271 3600
or email h c
s at ledge dot state
dot n h dot u s
d adjourning the meeting if the public
is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce to you the staff
that are
helping us assisting with this meeting
and jen ford who we know
will be hosting the meeting additional
staff providing support are christina
dreyer
and brad greenland this
is a work session on bills referred to
the education committee for interim
study
an executive session will follow when we
deal with each bill separately
copies of the interim study bills have
been posted on the main page of the
general court website
under the heading quote remote meetings
end quote
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
so let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call in attendance
when each member states their presence
place of where they
are and if anyone's in their room with
them during the meeting
which is required under the right to no
longer
so i will start the meeting by stating
that uh this is uh mel miler
is mel miler i'm calling from uh
do we know what that noise is jen
it looks like it might be coming from
dave's um
speakers
okay i don't know maybe a volume setting
or something like that
so this is a i'm mel miller i'm calling
from port clyde nain and i'm here
in my uh room by myself uh david
uh luno uh dave luno here in hopkinton
with ozzy the long-haired dachshund uh
art art ellison here in concord
uh i'm i'm alone in my house dave
dougherty
okay all right got it he's here
all right he's here linda tanner
uh linda tanner i'm in george's mills uh
by myself
uh rick glad rick ladd is here in
haverhill
uh with uh my wife teaching the
two kids homeschooling that they'll
probably pass back and forth now and
then
uh sue mullen sue mullen here in bedford
patty cornell patty cornell in
manchester
alone tamara lee
uh this is tamara lay in northampton um
with my two
daughters who are in in enhanced
virtual learning class at the moment
call reel
hey cole here in my office uh might be
some folks
in and out as we go along here great to
see everyone
jim allard yes jim allard here at home
in pittsfield uh
uh my wife is in the building but uh
probably
won't uh come through here at all but uh
we may be invaded by a couple of golden
retrievers who know
no discipline steve woodcock
good morning mel i'm here at in north
conway
with my wife walking in and out and my
dog who is now
blown out our other acl and going
nowhere
yes i am here in manchester by myself
except for my phone
okay dave you want to try today door do
you want to try it again
how's this very good better good okay
i'm here i'm alone in the room
my wife may be uh coming in out of the
kitchen
i'm in pembroke uh we are also
pass how about christina christina
dreyer are you there
i am here okay where where are you
christina
i am in the legislative office building
and
yes thank you thank you and then jan
four
yes and if i um can interrupt i believe
that representative elliott may be
connected by phone but he's in the
attendee list um
if i may i'll allow him to talk sure and
you can you can get his information
thank you
bob are you there representative elliot
if you've
phoned in um please press star six to
unmute yourself
so clearly i'm not getting a response
right um
i can ask uh brad if he can reach out um
if he's able to get through to
representative elliott
it's the phone number appears to be the
same as what we have
on file but we'll just give it a try and
if he's able to connect you'll see him
come in
okay then we'll do that address that
when he does come in
well what uh what i don't want to
indicate to everyone is that we have 11
interim study bills that we'll be
dealing with
the action that we are to take this
morning are really
two options one is to either recommend
for future legislation or two
not recommend for future legislation
i also want to say that even though we
recommend
future or not future legislation this
does not prohibit
someone from filing a bill on the
particular topic
that we're dealing with we will first
deal with an open session i will open
the session on each bill
asking dave luno to basically cite the
number of the bill
and read the indication that notes for
the bill
we will then close once we have an
opportunity to talk
if there are questions or issues around
that i will then close that
open work session and moving immediately
to an exact session on that bill
and we will then take a motion and have
an action
on that and which there will be a roll
call vote for each of those
recommendations the committee should
also know
that there's only going to be there is a
only a single
report that is made for these interim
bills
and that report will reflect both the uh
the various opinions on that particular
bill
with only a single report coming out
we will if you want to speak
during the session just raise your hand
in front and we'll recognize you
so you have a chance to
speak are there any questions regarding
the process
c none then i will ask david
to open our first bill which is house
bill
716. david
sure happy to do that mr chair thank you
very much good morning
so i'd like to i'd like to open the work
session on house bill
716.
so uh thank you again mr chair um uh
house bill 716 is relative to
transportation costs of
certain pupils and making an
appropriation therefore
um it was sponsored by
representative flanagan representative
ladd uh
i think maybe if people recall back to
the
here would you like me to speak on this
map yes yes please okay
um uh it was uh it was a long day of
hearings and i think it was uh towards
the end of
the day and um and
my notes are a little um um
brief on it but i think there was some
confusion
with respect to the rsa the the relevant
rsa
that um that this would need to be um
where it would need to go but it was
specific to
um to um provide reimbursements to
school districts
that um that face transportation costs
uh following a court-ordered placement
uh
to uh to a school where the where the
student is um
is currently attending um
the um uh i uh you know my feeling is
that it's
it's certainly a very good um uh
policy i think it needs some work and um
and i think it probably needs to be
folded into um
into the work that the uh any any work
with regards to school funding
specifically transportation and these
are things that the
school funding commission is also taking
up so um
so i would um when we get into an exec
i would i would recommend it for um for
further legislation
any questions or comments on uh house
bill 716.
yeah i have one uh mel
um when when this bill was introduced it
was a result
of a student that was in district a
being placed by the court in district b
and its latter part of the school year
and the student educationally is best
served remaining
in school district a
however the child is now legally being
placed in district b
and now it's up to district b if they're
going to provide that transportation
cost
to district a there are some issues with
this
especially when you get into some real
high cost
transportation issues associated with an
iep or special education services
however the intent and the principle
behind this
i think is a good one and i i think that
it needs to go forward but i believe as
um
dave luno just mentioned there perhaps
are some issues with the
respect to reference to a specific rsa
and also having more information in
terms of how this is going to really
impact the financial costs
of the of the district who's now re
response has agreed to
accept this child and keep the child
but um is not any longer
receiving that special ed support so
funding support um that's the comment
it was an issue that we could not
resolve in committee
quickly um therefore we thought it
needed more study which we have not been
able to give it
appearing to have no further comments i
will close the work session on that
and open the executive session on house
bill 716
and i'd call on dave luno for a motion
um thank you mr chair i would move that
we recommend this for
a future legislation thank you that's
seconded by uh dave
dougherty uh are there further comments
or questions
seeing none i will have our clerk
representative tanner call the role on
house bill 716
representative tanner thank you mr chair
representative luno
yes representative luno votes yes
representative shaw
yes representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
yes representative dory votes yes
representative lay
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner votes yes
representative ellison yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yes representative mullen votes yes
representative real
yes representative real votes yes
representative alone
representative woodcock yes
representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd yes representative
ladvotes yes
representative cordelli representative
elliott representative boehm
representative wolf representative
allard
yes representative allard votes yes
chairman um miler yes
chairman milor votes yes the resulting
vote is 13 years
zero nays thank you very much i'll close
exact session on house bill 716
and open the work session on house bill
representative luno please read the
message
thank you mr chair uh house bill 723 is
relative to requiring a criminal
history records check for applicants for
teaching certification
um it was recommended interim study
following a subcommittee
session i believe chaired by
representative tanner
and also including representatives
ellison and alec
uh appearing not not to have any
comments
i will close the work session on 723 and
open the executive session
on house bill 723 and i like to call on
uh yes i'd like to um
refer for for further
legislation so
are you referring are you referring it
for further legislation or not
no further not referring it for further
legislation
i believe that uh we decided that
i'll second for discussion okay it's
moved and seconded by representative
shaw and ladd
uh can we hear the did the subcommittee
have any work on this
you mentioned three names of committee
members
i don't know who that is um we met
several times
and one of the things about this um
background the requiring the criminal
history background checks
record checks um it's kind of in a
state of of of revision they
they work to try to get um school bus
drivers with background checks in
multiple districts
um there's a new system i think with the
department of safety at least they were
talking about that
about um instituting a new system so
that
they could do substitute teachers nurses
bus drivers and i think that system is
also
uh possibly something the department of
education will want to look at
um it really uh the bill as we had it
really wasn't ready for uh prime
time or for further um
further future legislation i i think the
future legislation has to be a brand new
um bill you know
coming in okay jim is that your hand
jim is that your hand up yeah go ahead
uh yes it is
uh as a member of that subcommittee
uh i i would concur what representative
tanner just said
that there were some significant issues
uh
uh with the department of safety's
current
uh capability both in terms of staffing
and technology
to take on uh an additional burden of
this magnitude
and so uh we were kind of
left saying this is a great idea
uh but
right now uh we don't have
uh the needed resources in place uh
to actually institute it
all right uh further comment yes uh
representative woodcock
thank you mr chairman uh this is
representative tanner allen
in their subcommittee meeting uh was
there any discussion about the
multiple background checks required for
across districts
for for example we have up here uh if
you work in two different districts in
the same sau you have to get
uh yeah uh mr uh chair yes uh-huh go
ahead
um yes there were and uh and in
from what i understand they're currently
looking and
uh may have in place a way to give
background checks criminal
history checks to bus drivers from
multiple districts
um and i think that once that system
that's that's kind of what
we looked at and then you know the
department of safety realized there was
a real problem and they needed to get a
new
system and find out who's responsible
for what
but i think it's in the works and and
some of it's already probably done
thank you representative all right
it should be on muted now yeah um thank
you representative miler
i think we got to be in regardless which
way we go on this bill
i i agree it needs more study and more
work
we don't want to come across as an
education committee
saying that our people applying for
certification don't need a criminal
background check
that's absolutely i think we would all
support the need for ensure that the
people in our classrooms in
our schools are having criminal
background checks
there are some concerns if if a student
for example is trying to get into a
post-secondary education
course that's dealing with teaching in a
classroom
you need to have a criminal background
check even before you get
to the school and you're you're you're
working as a full-time or a part-time
employee
with certification um it's just a matter
of costs
okay are they going to then have to
submit to another criminal background
check
maybe a year later when they're out to
get the first job that they're
applying for um i i think the criminal
background check is
needed uh i think we also need to be
careful that we're not mixing up
apples and oranges here where we have
those people requiring
certification and those employees
not requiring certification
uh so i think the concept needs to move
forward
the bill as it's written uh cannot move
i represent tanner uh thank you um i
just want to point out that this
this bill is about um people people that
are employed
whether they're teachers who are
certified or bus drivers or
they they have to get the criminal
background checks this bill actually had
two parts to it one
one part of it increased the the areas
of
criminal background history that they
were looking at including like arson
and some of the other things that hadn't
been initially in it so that was one
part that
and simple assault there was a issue
about assault as i remember
that we were kind of concerned that it
was going to include
people that may not really need to be
included
the other part of this bill was that the
state department of education
wants to have people who apply for
certification they finish college
they finish their student teaching which
they've taken two background checks at
that point
and before they get their certification
from the department of education
they want another criminal background
check and that is because they're
they found um we weren't certain how
many
but they found people who were they said
a significant number
getting certification in new hampshire
and then went and taught someplace else
and didn't have a background check and
those other places that they may be
teaching assumed that they had
and didn't do an employment background
check so
there were a lot of moving parts to this
bill and as i said i think it needs to
not only the department of safety needs
to come up with
and they may have already different uh
ways to to approach this
as well as being a little bit more
certain about what exactly is happening
that people are getting certifications
in new hampshire through the department
of education to teach
but then don't teach in new hampshire
yeah i think
the the issue of reciprocity of a
certification
from our state to another state was
clearly one of the issues that was
pointed out in testimony as i recall
so we have before us a motion to
recommend future legislation
moved by shaw represe seconded by lad
are there further comments on this
particular uh recommendation
um mr chairman yes sir i i
i what i misinterpreted
what i wanted for or i i didn't state
what i wanted for this because
i remember now from the discussion and i
don't have my notes in front of me
unfortunately
um that this particular bill
really has too much in it and just
reading this one line this is the part
that i agreed with
but there's so much other stuff that was
in it
that i don't think this particular bill
should go forward
so i'm going to withdraw my motion and
recommend that uh and if uh
if representative vlad wants to to go
forward he can but i'm gonna withdraw my
motion
so you're withdrawing your motion to
move forward recommend
that this go forward rick what's your
position on this
yes i'm i we've had our discussion and
that i think we were successful in
conveying the point that yes we support
teacher certification background checks
but this is not the bill to do
it with okay so i'm open for
another motion then i move that we'd not
recommend
okay uh representative on a second
okay representative shaw moves not to
recommend future legislation on this
um moved by
seconded by lad further comments on this
particular bill
a nun appearing i'll ask the clerk to
call the role the recommendation
is not to recommend future legislation
on this particular bill
thank you mr chair um representative
luno
yes representative luno votes yes
representative shaw
yes representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
yes representative doherty votes yes
representative leg
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner votes yes
representative ellison yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yes representative mullen votes yes
representative real
yes representative rio votes yes
yes representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
yes representative ladd votes yes
representative allard
yes representative allard votes yes
chairman
miler yes chairman milor votes yes
13 to 0. thank you very much
i'll close the executive session on
house bills 723
and now open the work session on house
bill
1163 representative representative luno
thank you very much mr chair um house
bill 1163
is um is titled requiring schools to
update documents and software to include
the option of identifying a student
as non-binary
we uh just a brief uh summary we
heard the bill uh on january 29th
executed on february 25th
interim study um it was voted 15-3
uh on interim study there were um
some comments that um that that came up
uh during the hearing and exec with
respect to
uh uh maybe a um
an effective date that would provide
time for a school district and the state
to uh to make implementations and a
fiscal note
uh with respect to the costs that
that would have to be incurred at the uh
at the state
local um local levels uh i believe
um uh we did reach out to uh the
department
who provided uh us with some information
on that and i'd certainly yield to
um to the prime sponsor with any
thoughts on that
the uh committee is now considering
house bill 1163
we're open for discussion and work
session on 1163
uh representative woodcock thank you
representative milo
uh 1163 is is a very uh
important bill in terms of students and
parents
youngsters are constantly put at
additional stress as are the parents as
they move from grade to grade school to
school
as the termination of their binary and
non-binary classification
currently the systems as we heard in the
testimony in the larger schools
have a contract that uh cost free
basically updating if it is a law
uh and the smaller systems in the past
and some of the more
progressive systems have found
workarounds the real issue becomes
doe changing their documentation piece
and how they account for these
youngsters
i think was the most recent figure was
around 20 000
as a financial note for doe and i don't
think this bill should be driven
by does needs but rather by student
apparent needs mr chairman
and i think clearly that this non-binary
bill um
needs to come back up for future
legislation to allow students
to progress through our system in the
most comfortable and socially emotional
effective way thank you thank you uh
other comments uh on house bill uh
1163.
mr chair yes uh representative luno um i
support everything
the the prime sponsor just said um all i
was suggesting with respect to the
fiscal note is that
uh is that we need to be transparent in
terms of costs
and uh i was i was encouraged to see
that the that the cost
seemed relatively marginal um given
you know what we know our educational
costs and so many other areas
so um so i would i would certainly also
support this for future legislation
further comments uh cnn i will close the
work session
and open the exec session on house bill
and i'd call on representative woodcock
for a motion please
thank you mr chairman i would recommend
that hbill house bill 1163 be
recommended for future legislation thank
you uh seconded by
representative dougherty uh the floor is
now open for further conversation
scene none we will move to a vote i'll
call the
clerk to call the roll call on 1163
please the motion
is to recommend future legislation
thank you mr chair representative luno
yes representative luno votes yes
representative shaw
yes representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
yes representative dougherty votes yes
representative lee
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner votes yes
representative ellison yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yes representative mullenvilces
representative real
yes representative real votes yes
representative woodcock
yes representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
no representative vlad votes no
representative allard no
representative allard votes no uh
chairman miler
yes chairman miler votes yes
the uh vote tally is 11 yays and two
nays
okay the uh the motion to move uh house
bill 1163 has been approved and will
uh be so noted i'd now like to open up
the uh
work session on house bill uh 1232
representative luno sure thank you very
much mr chair
um just also a quick question of the
chair
um i think our our committee is
responsible for drafting
the interim study recommendation um
and are we going to follow um practice
of the
the motion um thank you for that thank
you back clarifications those who are
moving
their respective uh bill will be
responsible for drafting the report
and again the uh and these particular
things the report does not have to be
exhaustive
you basically indicate uh the nature of
the conversation
uh and then forward that to me for uh
for editing thank you
thank you for that clarification david
so and
and and also i i think you know unlike
unlike other bill reports we don't have
majority and minority
rights as i noted earlier there's a
single report
that reflects the conversation of the
interim of the exec
session right right
you know so so happy to and you know
like on a split vote like we just had
if there's if there's something that
needs to be added
um when do you want these reports um i
would refer to jen
uh on this uh when do these reports have
to be submitted uh jen we're not on a
tight timeline but
i think within the week would be great
to give people plenty of time but
not let them get kind of forgotten about
okay so we'll establish a date before we
end on when those reports are due
okay david you want to comment uh
introduce uh absolute 1232 please
yes thank you thank you mr chair so
house bill 1232
is titled relative to the burden of
proof in special education hearings
it was heard on february 12th and exact
on february 26th
it was um i believe had a 17-2
vote for um for interim study
and that's what i've that's what i've
got on it
okay so the uh work session is now open
for the conversation on house bill 12 uh
32 comments from the committee
uh i i'll comment a little bit uh this
was this was the bill
that turned the burden of proof in
disputed special education
cases from uh the aggrieved party which
is generally the
family of a student to the school
district
and we heard tremendous testimony on
this
um legal testimony testimony from the
doe
and uh it's it appeared from
we we actually had a subcommittee that
was appointed from
our original discussion and
representative doherty was on that
subcommittee as was representative
cordelli
and the subcommittee came forward with
the recommendation
uh for interim study but
this uh this this bill really would
upend what we know as conflict
resolution between the department of ed
and
the public so um
i i think i think it needs more than
interim study
appearing to have none we will close the
work session on uh
house i apologize for interrupting
um i just wanted to bring to your
attention that someone um has their hand
up in the attendee section it's
completely at your discretion whether
you'd like
to entertain any input from outside
members but i just wanted to let you
know
uh thank you i think we're going to move
forward in
in an exact session this is a
conversation
with the committee and i'm gonna i'm
just gonna move forward on this
uh so uh no further comments on
in the work session here so we're gonna
close the work session and move to the
exec
session on house bill 1232 and i call on
representative mullen for a motion
uh thank you chairman i am uh making the
motion
that house bill 1232 not be recommended
for
additional legislation and that's
seconded by
uh representative cornell the floor is
now open
uh for conversations on house bill uh
1232. can i um speak to my mother yes
you can
yes you can thank you we actually
heard uh a tremendous amount of
information from the department of
education and learned
a great deal from the department of
education around this bill
most specifically we heard from bridget
perry and the
learner support special education
division
she handles all the complaints that come
in from
the the public we heard from richard
farrell and diana fenton who
are appointed to investigate any
uh employee misconduct teacher
misconduct that takes place in the
school system
we heard from stephen berwick who is in
charge of mediation
neutral conferencing and hearings
and virtually all of those people
said that that using this
cadre that the department of education
now
uh it now imp implements this center for
appropriate dispute resolution in
special ed
their motto is prevention and resolution
through partnership and collaboration
um so i i i would say that this
this appears to be a problem looking for
uh
i mean a solution looking for a problem
and that this is a good opportunity for
us to partner with the department of
education and allow them to
utilize the process that they already
have in place
thank you representative mullen further
comments on the house bill
1232 representative dougherty
i'd just like to uh state my support for
comments on this and i was in the same
[Music]
hearing hearings with her and i agree
with her comments
thank you thank you further comments on
the committee
uh appearing to have none i will call
the clerk to call the roll
the recommendation is not to pursue
further
legislation on this made by uh rep st
mullen seconded by representative
cornell please call the roll thank you
mr chair
representative luno yes representative
luno votes yes representative shaw
yes representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
representative dougherty
yes representative daugherty votes yes
representative lay
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner votes yes
representative ellison yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yeah representative mullen votes yes
representative real
you're muted yes okay representative
reel votes yes
representative woodcock yes
representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
yes representative ladd votes yes
representative allard yes representative
allard votes yes chairman
miler yes chairman miler votes yes
the the result is 13 to 0.
thank you very much we'll close the
execution on uh
12 house bill 1232 open the work session
on house bill 1282 representative
representative luno thank you very much
mr chair house bill
1282 is an act relative to changing a
pupil school
or assignment because of a manifest
educational hardship
my notes don't have a whole lot of
testimony on it
but i think more significant to the or
more germane to the
to the conversation this morning um is
that
a similar bill um uh house bill 1328
that would that i introduced along with
my colleague representative ladd
directed to the same um subject of
manifest educational hardship
uh was passed in the house and was uh
assembled by the senate
into the education omnibus bill uh which
uh which was house bill 1558 and um
was uh was passed by the legislature and
signed into law by the governor so
um so i don't i i don't believe that
that 1282 is uh is necessary
any longer for consideration and uh and
i'll be moving that at the not
recommended for
future legislation you you'll recall
that uh this was a
bill that uh represented luna and ladd
worked on
really over two sessions and um
a lot of work was done on on their
original bill to basically address this
issue of manifest hardship so
um i would concur with the represent
luno that
this is not necessary uh other comments
uh
yes i i'd also congratulate
representative miler
uh we've we've got 1328 there's no
longer a need for this bill
okay further conversations on the work
session on uh
12 on 1282 appearing to have none i will
close the work session on 1282 and move
to executive session
on 1282 and i'd uh call on
representative luna for a motion
thank you mr chair i recommend uh this
not be recommend or i move that this not
be recommended for further
legislation seconded by representative
shaw
uh further conversation regarding uh
house bill 1282
uh only in writing up the uh
the findings uh that the majority is
going to have here i think we also have
to state that
it's already been done via another yes
yeah absolutely that would be part be
part of the report
uh further questions or comments
appearing to have no further comments
i'll call the
clerk to call the roll the motion is not
to move this recommend this for further
legislation
representative if you support it you'll
vote yes if you're opposed you vote no
representative tanner please thank you
chairman
representative luna yes representative
luno votes yes
representative shaw yes representative
shaw votes yes
representative cornell yes
representative cornell votes yes
representative dougherty
yes representative dougherty votes yes
representative lay
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner votes yes
representative ellison yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yes representative mullen votes yes
representative real
yes representative rio votes yes
representative woodcock
yes representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd yes representative
ladd votes yes
representative allard yes representative
allard votes yes chairman miler
yes chairman miler votes yes the result
is 13-0
13-0 vote means that the recommendations
for no further action
has passed i will close the executive
session on house bill
1282 and open the work session
on house bill 1344. representative luno
thank you mr chair house bill 1344
is titled an act relative to
reimbursement of transportation costs
for students attending i believe
following um
following some extensive discussion on
in school funding commission
is that this is an important um uh topic
and um and and um and i believe that
this uh
bill is um is it would be important to
have um
uh to have this addressed
comprehensively uh
during um during in our school funding
work
and uh i would be supporting um future
legislation for this
representative shaw yes the problem with
my bill is that um
it really this is a great bill and it's
very important
manchester and exeter and nashville
uh they're about the only three that it
really affects
but what happens is the cte people
are get furious about it because of the
funding
because it takes away funding from other
areas so
i would rather see this bill go away
and i would rather see a
the transportation for cte to be
addressed in a package for all
transportation and be included in the
new funding
legislations that will come out for
adequate education from the
education funding commission that's been
established
further comments uh representative vlad
um you know i i support what
representative shaw is saying however
i just want to make sure that everybody
understands
and i know that represent luna and
represent mylar you do
because you're on that commission and
and of course represent luna chairs it
um yes transportation is a
a discussion item in that commission a
hot discussion at that
and where we place this as we are
discussing the
the other area of catastrophic aid or
special education aid
is that to be part of adequacy or is
that going to be
remaining a separate budget item
in a separate category with separate
funding sources
i believe that your policy
representative shaw
is a good policy i think that any
student
that requires transportation to a cte
center regardless of whether that cte
center is within the district or not
it's a safety issue it's an issue of
trying to get more students
participating in ctes
and coming out with those valuable
skills so
this bill the the intent of the bill
the policy behind the bill is solid what
has always harmed us in the end
is that yes we only have x number of
dollars in the pot
and the cte centers don't like
distributing it you know any
further out than they're already doing
so it's a funding
issue the policy side which our
committee is says
i think we should be moving this forward
at least getting this concept moving
forward and
and and resolving for once we need to be
doing this
well i i think what it needs is a revamp
um because um
talking with um uh
eric i can't name friedrich or whatever
his last name is
over at d.o.e um he feels that
that the language um
will affect some other areas of
the law and so i need to
i need to resubmit a bill and i need to
to do it along with him
and make sure that that uh the bill i
submit
uh doesn't um
open up the door for a whole bunch of
other funding that
uh uh has unintended consequences let's
put it that way
so uh that's why i want this one to just
go away
hey uh representative luno thank you
thank you very
much mr chair um and i you know i agree
with everything that's
that's been been said on this i would i
would only respectfully ask
representative shaw
to um to if if you're going to be
looking at
um at working on legislation that
affects school funding
uh work work i i think in conjunction
with
representatives lad and myself um on
that so that we don't have competing
um you know bills going through uh
because
all right great thanks okay represent
mullen
yeah i was just going to support what
representative shaw was offering
as her explanation because i was sort of
the
third leg of the stool of conversation
about this with eric froworth at the doe
because the reality is that uh in
changing the definitions as
representative shaw's bill would have
done
other districts would have um money
would have been taken away from
other districts in order to supplement
the transportation costs
in the larger school districts where
transporting from one side of town to
the other is the equivalent of
um coming in from another town
so uh yeah it was a little bit like the
gingerbread man
in terms of if we change this then it's
going to change that
and it's going to unintendedly arrive
here and change that
so i um would listen to representative
shaw's concerns
about the language in the bill not the
policy but the
language thank you uh further
conversation
in this work session we
we uh represent that approved the first
bill
today the 716
to move forward um even though we
recognize there are a lot of issues with
it
now we're dealing with a similar
situation here
and we've been dealing with this issue
and several years back representative
shaw i
also sponsor the bill doing exactly what
this bill is doing
we are a policy committee and we're
recognizing
that there are really significant issues
if eric was here from
as dave dougherty knows from the
cte advisory commission that
there's a state such as delaware
which has more students participating in
over 50 percent of the high school
school
students there participate in a cte
class and come out with a cte skill
and they spend they have the same amount
of students as we have in this state
yet they're putting more emphasis
dollars into their cte
program we're turning this bill down
simply because the other cte programs
are going to cry
you know we're not going to be funded
this at the same rate
our funding program for ctes is broken
we also have to make a significant
decision here regarding
is this going to be a part of adequacy
or not part of adequacy
what happens if it's not then it's going
to remain the way it is
and we have the kids in exeter nashua
and manchester
still being screwed um so
whether it comes forward in the same uh
language barb
uh or you change it around to stay on
task with the principle and the concept
and the policy behind it i think
something should move forward
i will okay further
comments further comments said uh dave
dougherty
just uh briefly um
i agree with rick on this i think um i
think this is a good bill
um i think just philosophically i think
it would be a good idea
to be safe and move this forward um
it can always be um amended
uh or itl at a point where we know we're
gonna be able to do
something out of the funding commission
i just think we'd err on the side of
safety on this and
and move it forward thanks thank you
further comments uh
represent tanner i have a question if if
it's recommended for
further legislation um it still can be
changed significantly
isn't that right that representative
shaw can change it and
it wouldn't she wouldn't be tied to this
bill no no no
no that's right no okay so it looks like
there's some
support for the concept of moving
forward as we've talked about it here so
let's close the work session and let me
open uh the
exec session on house bill 13
44 and i'll call who would like to make
a motion to move this forward
uh representative vlad uh yes thank you
very much representative miller
i'd like to move this bill forward
uh dealing with the cte transportation
issue
okay and i'll have seconded by shaw by
allan
okay a move by lad seconded by allard
to move this forward is there further
yes um we have
um a funding issue with our cte programs
that's broader than just
transportation we have a tuition problem
as well
where we're funding so many students x
number of students
and and some districts are capping the
number of students that are able to
participate
uh we should be doing just the opposite
with our cte
career technical education is a key to
our success
i'm meeting our goal by 2025 of having
65 percent
of our our our our kids with some kind
of a skill
or post-secondary degree transportation
is critical
and i think that our saying yes to this
we will communicate that
you know we need all our students not
just the students that are outside
external and manchester we need
all our students participating and
and that includes all those that were
missing
throughout this entire state so i would
like to move this forward
simply because the principles involved
the concept and the policy
thank you very much uh further comments
[Music]
appearing to see none uh the
recommendation
and moved by lads seconded by allard is
to move uh
1344 for future legislation
uh i'd like to if you're support of that
you'll vote yes if you're opposed you
vote no
i'd like to have a clerk call the role
please thank you mr chair
representative luno yes representative
luna votes yes
representative shaw yes
representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
representative dougherty
yes representative daugherty votes yes
representative
lay yes representative leyvo yes
representative tanner votes yes
representative ellison
yes representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yes representative mullen votes yes
representative real
yes representative real votes yes
representative woodcock
yes representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
yes representative the lad votes yes
representative allard
yes representative allard votes yes
chairman miler
yes chairman miler votes yes the result
is 13
yays zero days so this uh so 1344
uh is authorized or recommended to to
move forward thank you very much
i'd like to close the executive session
on 1344
and move to open the uh work session
on house bill 1469 uh representative
luna please
thank you very much mr chair house bill
1469 is an act relative to hazing
at educational institutions uh
it was heard in committee on january
23rd
and it was exact on um on february 25th
i believe it was recommended interim
study at a vote of
16 to 2 during the hearing there was
substantial testimony um um
but i also think there were uh concerns
that um that uh this bill
was also a single committee uh bill
and it had several i think uh criminal
um
uh class eight felony class a
misdemeanor
uh uh elements to it and uh and
probably you know if it's um uh you know
something like
something like this would uh would
certainly need to be
considered by a by a second policy
committee
thank you uh conversation uh discussion
is now open
on house bill 1469 comments from the
committee
uh thank you mr chair um i just wanted
to say a couple things this is a
well-intentioned bill but it's pretty
convoluted it's got
quite a few mandates and um
i think uh it's not quite ready for
prime time and i think it needs
a lot more work in order to go forward
thank you representative vlad thank you
very much uh
represent miler when i testified before
the committee in support of this bill
i stated and i still feel this way i am
supportive of 1469's intent
in order to move forward with a bill
that best fits new hampshire it may be
wise to consider interim study in order
that the u.s university system new
hampshire
including trustees the community college
system of new hampshire
the higher education commission the
state board of education and the new
hampshire college and
university council be involved
uh and have time to review an
opportunity to submit findings on this
bill
um there's no room for hazing at all in
our post-secondary education
hazing is a practice with no value and
it's unhealthy however i do believe
that we need to move forward cautiously
and have a bill that is
been vetted amongst all these different
organizations that are involved
especially the university system new
hampshire
so i i'm i could go either way on this i
think the intent is a wonderful intent
however there are some major issues with
that this needs a lot of work
so perhaps this is one that we should be
going the other direction on thank you
further comments on on house bill 1469
appearing no for the comments i closed
the work session
and opened the executive session on
house bill 1469
by calling david dougherty for a motion
thank you mr chair i move to
not recommend further legislation
recommended by
dougherty seconded by shaw
the conversation the floor is now open
for discussion
on the recommendation of uh not to
uh representative representative luno
thank you very much mr chair so um uh
some of the things that um that i think
have have
were presented during the hearing and um
and in subsequent conversations uh have
have come out that both the
community college system in new
hampshire and the university system of
new hampshire
have have comprehensive policies in
place
[Music]
that really to address
the incidents of hazing uh that
um and um and provide um
uh you know uh enforcement
uh and um and working with uh with
internal uh campus authorities
um on this and uh and also
notification to what to all students as
to the
hazing policies on these institutions
and um
and i think to to a large degree uh this
bill could end up being sort of
uh a little bit um duplicative
and uh contradictory to uh to some of
the
the policies that are that are in place
now so
so i support um representative
daugherty's motion
okay uh further further conversations on
uh house bill
see none uh the motion was moved by
doherty second
by shaw that we do not recommend further
legislation on this
particular item if you support that
you'll vote yes if you're opposed you
won't know
the clerk will please call the role
thank you mr chair
representative luno yes representative
luno votes yes representative shaw
yes representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
representative daugherty
yes representative dougherty votes yes
representative lay
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner votes yes
representative ellison yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yes representative mullen votes yes
representative real
yes representative rio votes yes
representative woodcock
yes representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
yes representative ladd votes yes
representative allard
yes representative allard votes yes
chairman miler
yes chairman miler votes yes 13
yays zero nays so uh
fort house bill 1469 uh
it's uh approved that we will not
recommend further action on this
uh close the executive session on 1469
and now
we'll open the um
on house bill 1509 representative luno
thank you very much mr chair hospital
is titled an act relative to emergency
threat protection
orders for individuals at post-secondary
educational
institutions um uh
we had a we had an interesting path with
this one
uh we had a hearing back on february 5th
and exec on february 12th
uh the the original motion of ought to
pass
as amended uh had a split vote of 10
10 and uh and a subsequent um
vote brought this to uh interim study
um it's um it's a bill
that uh that stem i'm i'm the prime
sponsor on it so
uh so i might mr chair with your
indulgence uh just
for
was a bill that really came out of the
uh
the work of last year's public higher
education
study committee and we heard
specifically from from
a chief dean
at unh as well as as
other campus security professionals uh
within the university system that um
that one of the things that they were
looking for most
from uh from our state house
um was uh was please help us
please help provide the tools for us
that we can use
to uh to protect our students
particularly
in in instances where um where they may
be looking to
either harm themselves or um or other
students or
or faculty members uh around them and
um and the uh the text for um
for house bill 1509 um uh while it was
while it was driven by this
this need that we that we learned from
from higher education
um uh uh campus security
uh personnel uh really stemmed out of
out of uh research work that was
conducted by uh
by jim silver while he was at the
federal bureau of investigation
uh in analyzing mass shootings across
the
united states and and really looking at
them in
uh in strong detail um
uh the bill did have bipartisan
sponsorship
um uh uh but uh
uh but i think most importantly you know
it's a
it's an issue that still uh uh
is a uh is a problem on our our campuses
of higher education
and um and i'll be supporting a uh
recommendation for um uh for
further legislation uh to help address
it may not necessarily be this bill
but uh but i think we need to do
something to um to help reduce
uh instances of violence incident
instances of violence
uh on on you know at our institutes of
higher education
uh we're dealing with a vulnerable
population here and
um and uh and i think that would be an
appropriate way forward
thank you further comments on house bill
not appearing to have any further
comments
i will close the work session on 1509
and open the exact session on 1509 and i
call on representative luna for a motion
thank you mr chair i move that we
recommend this for future legislation
uh moved by luno uh seconded by lay
to move this for future legislation
further conversations
any further representative vlad
it was a 1010 vote of which
i i think that there was a lot of issues
when i
i know there were a number of issues
regarding language which was
very uh subjective
uh in one section where it says uh in
determining whether a danger exists the
court shall determine if the following
conditions are met
um risk-taking behavior well i have a
lot of risk-taking behavior
um some people may suffer from
depression
um giving away away uh prized
possessions
uh lack of interest in future plans
um some of those things you know can go
either way
and so but if you have four of those
things um
you're all sudden in this category i
think the bill was
uh crafted with a lot of nebulous
language in it
um and in definition of law enforcement
office
officials so with that this bill is
definitely not ready to move forward
well i know what the motion will
probably be i'll probably vote the
opposite
well the motion is to move it forward
yes
okay uh further further comments
on the recommendation to move uh 1509
forward non-appearing
representative tanner yes um initially i
voted um
in opposition to this bill um
because it uh again had some
ambiguous language in it and also i felt
as though the penalties
and the the tools that were given needed
to be
um vetted a little bit more and perhaps
um even go through another committee
committee that would deal more with the
particularly the issue of removing
firearms
okay we'll move forward to a vote uh
the the recommendation moved by uh luna
seconded by lay to move this legislation
forward for future consideration
if you are in support of that motion you
will vote yes
if you're opposed you'll vote no the
clerk will please call the roll
thank you mr chair representative luno
yes
representative luna votes yes
representative shaw
no representative shaw votes no
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
representative doherty
yes representative dougherty votes yes
representative lay
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner votes no
representative ellison yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yes representative mullen votes yes
representative
real yes representative rio votes yes
representative woodcock yes
representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
no representative lad votes no
representative allard no representative
allard votes no chairman miler
yes chairman miler votes yes
uh the tally is nine to four nine to
four the motion passes
uh and this will recommend that it do
that it will go forward noting
the opposition that's there uh i will
close the exact session on 1509
and open the work session on 1512.
representative luno thank you very much
mr chair hospital 1512
is titled an act relative to reducing
school food
waste and addressing child hunger um
for brief history it was heard on
january 28th
exact on february 26th
um you know the interim study
recommendation i think that
vote was 22 to nothing
um and um and we did hear i think some
some uh some uh very uh impassioned uh
testimony during the um during the
hearing
uh my notes uh suggest
that um that that potentially
some um some um uh amended language
may be uh maybe something that uh that
we're
considering down the road and um
and that it um uh would be worthy of um
of uh future considerations so
thank you the floor is now open for a
conversation regarding
1512. i can certainly add
to that as you as you may recall i think
the idea was um a very
um welcome one um
on our committee i think there was some
concern perhaps that
um the bill needed to be flushed out a
little bit
um with regard to packaging there were a
lot of questions that were raised i
think the fact that it was
20 to zero it was placed on the consent
calendar
for vote which actually as well known
didn't happen
um but i think this this might give the
um
uh lsr uh writers a a better opportunity
now to
maybe involve school nutrition directors
or even the superintendents association
um
it i'm i'm not sure if it'll even come
back to our committee
initially just um with regards to
the safety protocols anecdotally my
last night at our local budget committee
we heard
from our sau finance director talking
about the success they've had with
school lunch delivery um during um
the copa 19 um we've we've opted to
offer free breakfasts and lunches
um in the community and uh they've
learned a lot about
packaging and preparation and
delivery of these things different ways
to do it so i think there's a lot more
that could be
um done for this but um it was uh
it's it's a good idea so i will um
recommend that we uh move forward
further conversation uh regarding uh
house bill 1512
uh representative woodcock
thank you chairmal uh just a question if
i recall looking at my notes
this this specific bill dealt with is
this correct enabling legislation that
it wouldn't be required for all
communities
is that correct yeah that's my
understanding yes yeah okay
yes thank you i mean we could certainly
recommend that it be enabled
further further conversation uh
representative ladd
just trying to recall but i believe that
this program
is successfully done out in indiana
uh and a lot of success to the program
and it is as as i see it it's a positive
thing that we ought to be considering
anything we can do to help those
families that don't have food on the
table
i think we should try to do thank you
further comments seeing none will
close the work session and move to the
exec i'll open the exact session on
1512 and i'll recommend representative
lay for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move to
recommend future legislation regarding
hb
1512. seconded by uh representative
mullen
uh further conversation on uh house bill
on the recommendation to move this
forward
on 1512.
further conversation
i will ask the uh clerk to call the role
the motion
is to move this forward uh
move 1512 forward if you are in support
you vote yes
if you are opposed you'll vote no clerk
please call the roll
thank you mr chair representative luno
yes
representative luno votes yes
representative shaw yes
representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
representative dougherty
yes representative dougherty votes yes
representative lay
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner votes yes
okay come back to him or no
representative mullen yes representative
mullen votes yes
representative real yes representative
rio votes yes representative woodcock
yes representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
yes representative ladd votes yes
representative allard
yep representative allard votes yes
representative ellison
chairman miler yes chairman miler votes
yes
the tally is 12 yays zero nays uh the
motion then passes uh to move to move
1512 forward
and i will close the executive session
on 1512
and open the work session on 1635
representative luno thank you very much
mr chair
uh house bill 1635 is titled an act
requiring climate education
my my notes are actually a little thin
on them
on this one but i do have
that on february 26 it was exact
13-7 interim study
and and
let's see i don't see anybody on the
on our committee that was uh that was
in um as a sponsor on this but uh i'm
gonna end my remarks there
as i recall on this particular one i
think there was
uh a general concurrence of the need
for this to be covered in schools
there was a there was some question
around
another mandate another curriculum
mandate
uh to school districts and there were
some there was some concern that
this is already being taught in a number
of different ways
and that the bill as i recall was fairly
prescriptive
as it relates to the amount of time
and almost outlined a lesson plan
to consider this and so i think there
but the main concern as i recall was
do we want to have another mandate
another unfunded mandate that would go
to school districts
uh requiring them to deal with this
important topic
uh that's my recollection uh
representative mullen and representative
ladd
uh and not only not only was it
prescriptive
by grade level the language of the bill
was very confusing because
even members of our committee had a
different understanding of
exactly how much climate change
education was going to take place
at various grade levels so um
i i don't i don't think it's ready to
be looked at before some significant
work is done
representative glad yes everything
that's been said including what you said
uh representative miler is
right on the money um i was talking to
the people down the coal region
uh center here in hanover dealing with
cold
region climate and they're dealing with
issues like the permafrost how that's
disappearing in various places
but they also indicated this is part of
our overall
science curriculum and
when we start identifying specific areas
within
chapters or titles within and putting
that as a mandate
we're starting to get in the realm of
where the responsibility lies with
the school district for instruction and
curriculum
so i think we've given the prod topic
out to our schools through
our our our substantive criteria
for what an adequate education is by
saying you will have standards
associated with science
um so i don't think there's a need for
this bill i think it's
starting to get down in the weeds and we
better be careful going there
representative allard then
representative doherty
uh thank you mr chairman uh i
i am supremely confident in the uh the
capabilities of our
science curriculum educators and i i
think
uh this is a topic best left to them
uh to devise and structure and
and present and i think we
at this level uh trying to dictate
things are just gonna muck it up
thank you uh representative dougherty
uh thank you mr chair and um
i i agree this may not be a perfect bill
but i think this topic is so important
particularly in what's going on in this
country
over the past few months
i think it's important that we keep this
on the table
i'm in favor of moving this forward
i agreed it might be there might be some
need for
amendment or change in the bill i know
the prom
prime sponsor is not returning to the
house but i'm hoping that somebody else
will kind of pick up the torch and run
with it
um so i think i think it's valuable to
keep this
out there for people to understand how
important it is
thank you represent woodcock thank you
mr chairman uh
i would uh it's interesting to hear
representative allen talk about
scientists
doing science i like it um on a bit
and a bigger picture though my bigger
picture uh
this is in the standards and i agree
with with representative ladd
i'm very concerned that uh in any of
these prescriptive bills that were
constantly
uh requiring local districts
on what to do and what not to do on a
curricular basis uh or any other local
registration
i just believe we have to allow our
local school systems
and to deal with local curriculum within
the standards
i will not be supporting that okay thank
you
uh further com conversation regarding uh
house bill 1635
uh pairing to have none i will close the
work session
and open the uh exec section
on 1635 and i'd like to call on
representative woodcock
for a motion please thank you mr
chairman i would recommend that we do
not move this legislation forward
and seconded by shah the motion is now
on
now on the floor for conversation
uh appearing to have none the motion
before
the committee is not to uh recommend
further action on this by the house
if you are in support of that
recommendation you'll vote yes
if you're opposed you'll vote no and
i'll call the clerk to call the roll
please
thank you mr chairman representative
luno
yes representative luno votes yes
yes representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
representative
doherty no representative dougherty
votes no
representative lay no representative lay
representative representative tanner
votes yes
representative ellison representative
mullen
yes representative mullen votes yes
representative reel
yes representative rio votes yes
representative woodcock
yes representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
yes representative ladd votes yes
representative
allard yes representative alert votes
yes
chairman miler yes and you have
representative
ellison is also on the line he just
needs to unmute himself
okay representative ellison or
yes yes representative ellison votes yes
representative miler yes representative
miler votes yes
the tally is 11 yays two nays
thank you very much the uh with that
vote the
recommendation is not to have the
climate
education program go for recommendation
go forward
i will close the uh exact session
on 1635 and move to open the work
session
on 1682 uh representative luno
thank you very much mr chair um house
bill 1682 is titled an act requiring
schools to maintain
food allergy plans to address food
allergy safety
and training um
my notes show that uh we held a hearing
on this
back on january 21st
and then uh executed on february 18th
and um
it was recommended to go to interim
study
um i'm showing in my also in my notes
that
at least a couple different
amendments that um that were put
forth on it and
and and i think there was still some
some
some committee discussion on on how it
may apply to
uh to non-public schools
training with respect to um to
the um the food allergy safety uh impact
on
um on day care contract bus services
so a lot of open items
on it but but i sense a real willingness
or real interest i should say to um
to see some movement going forward on
this representative cornell
yeah the subcommittee met numerous times
in her
testimony from numerous organizations
and
everyone thought it was very important
to look at and do something about but it
was a lot bigger than
the bill or the amendments and um
you know the fiscal part of it came into
how much would it
cost and who should be
um trained and how will they be trained
and then it got into bus drivers
and taxi drivers and it just got
really really big so we thought it was a
really good bill but it really needs a
lot more work
thank you thank you uh further comments
appearing not to see any further
comments i will close the work session
and open the executive session on 1682
and i'll call on representative tanner
for a motion
thank you mr chair um i recommend
that this bill be uh recommended for
future legislation
thank you uh i think it's a move by uh
moved by tanner uh seconded by cornell
uh
representative tanner you want to speak
to your motion yes thank you i
we had an issue at the school that i um
taught at um
a very severe issue with food allergies
but i think it
it's also important to recognize all the
other allergies that that students have
and in so many of our schools now
there's not a school nurse
there's still no school nurse
coordinator at the doe
and we have people at elementary schools
who are simply the secretary who are
taking care of first aid issues and
anything that happens and unfortunately
allergies are something
that you need to be trained on that time
is critical that a person could um
suffer an allergy attack uh
anaphylactic shock and die within
minutes uh if they don't get the proper
treatment um
so i think this is a critical issue uh
if for no other reason than to
make schools aware of it um and to get
them
to work on producing plans and and
having something in place
to deal with it so i think it's a very
important bill to move forward
thank you further comments on the
recommendation to move this
further comments see none uh the
recommendation move by tanner seconded
by cornell
to move 1682 forward
uh in next session if you are in support
of that
motion you will vote yes if you're
opposed you vote no the clerk will
please call the roll
thank you mr chair representative luno
yes
representative luno votes yes
representative shaw
yes representative shaw votes yes
representative cornell
yes representative cornell votes yes
representative dougherty
yes representative dougherty votes yes
representative lay
yes representative lay votes yes
representative tanner
votes yes representative ellison yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative mullen
yes representative mullen repres uh
votes yes
representative reel yes representative
rio votes yes
yes representative woodcock votes yes
representative ladd
no representative lad votes no
representative
allard yes representative ellard votes
yes uh chairman miler yes
chairman miler votes yes the tally is
twelve to one
twelve to one with twelve to one vote
the recommendation of moving the four
of twelve of 1682 forward has been
passed and i will close the executive
session
on 1682. um
it looks like jen i'm looking to you as
uh have we
completed the work for this interim uh
these interim bills now you've completed
your work for today we just need the
statements and then you guys will be all
finished
i would i would suggest that uh again
those who are moving
their respective uh pieces that they
have those to me
by monday the 28th is that okay jen
absolutely yeah okay so that gives us
about a week to get them to me
and again these do not have to be long
statements
they basically just had to state the
position of the committee and
where there was some opposition to them
that that
opposition needs to be also incorporated
into that single statement that you'll
be making before we go
i do want to alert you to a
a potential joint house senate education
committee meeting
uh i believe it's going to be scheduled
for october
7th and the purpose of that
session will be to review
the school openings we'd like to have a
chance to
revisit with those people who presented
at the original joint session several
weeks ago
and both jay senator khan and i
are working to try to identify what has
worked
and what have been some of the problems
and some recommendations for going
forward
so i'm just giving you an alert to that
i believe it's going to be on the 7th
so just kind of keep a heads up and
we'll let you know
when that finally is uh is confirmed
uh anything else jen before we close
this uh this committee
nothing i'll just give you all a high
five for being so concise and working
through the
11 bills was one of our uh biggest
number for each committee so you guys
did an awesome job
thank you for that thanks a lot for
everybody attending
and uh for for rick and tamara who are
dealing with uh kids at home uh god i
love you
it's a tough it's a tough situation i
know and uh
but your experiences will help the
committee i'm sure in the future so
all right so thanks so much and uh we'll
we'll
we'll see you soon in a couple weeks uh
take care now and
thanks for participating thanks very
much thank you